oh hi Brian I'm David Rosenberg the
chairman of pykrete technologies and
this CEO from a gonna groove and what
keeps me motivated is I focus on clean
tech solutions for our planet and while
there's a lot of concern rightful
concern about what's going on there's
also a lot of reason to be optimistic so
I'm a technology enthusiast and when you
get around other technology enthusiasts
and you feel the passion of the
solutions coming down the pipe is it's
good of it and it's there goes the
science is there and i think the science
is going to help us come a long way so
there's obviously there's behavioral
issues that we need to improve upon and
will subside on issues that we need to
improve our own will but the technology
solutions are coming fierce and and
you're a lot of Peter there's hope
excitement from the financial sectors
and money as well as the managers as
well as then R&D people teams that are
together collaborating well in this
interconnected world ideas and
businesses have been never been easier
to grow all the various a great time